[ Music ]
Satya Nadella: All right.
Good morning!
[ Cheering ]
[ Applause ]
Good morning!
It's fantastic to be back
in San Francisco at Build.
It's always fun to be at
developer conferences
at times of great change.
You know, developer
conferences are always
about understanding tech shifts,
understanding the new stack.
But it's also about
really coming to grips
with the new opportunity,
right, for us as developers,
for the companies
that we work at,
as well as the broader world.
So today we're going
to unpack this.
This conference is
all about that.
And if there's one key
takeaway, it would be this:
How do you all participate fully
in thisFrontier
intelligence ecosystem?
Right?
It's not about any one piece
of technology that you'll hear
about or even the
platform itself.
It's about the value that you
can build, you can compound,
you can create on
top of the platform.
That's what a developer
conference needs to be about,
and that's what
we will focus on.
So let's kind of get into it.
Let's take a look
at this AI stack
that this conference
is going to unpack
in a great amount of detail.
It starts, of course, with
the compute fabric, right,
that ubiquitous compute fabric
that spans the edge
and the cloud.
You then have this layer,
which is the emerging layer,
where you have the
models, you have context,
you have the tools the
models can access.
And then on top of that,
you have the runtime
where you deploy your agents
and applications that you built
on top of the context layer,
on top of the model layer.
And then, of course, you
have the best tooling
to do all of this.
And then you have the
security, the compliance,
and the governance, right?
That's the simplest
form of the tech stack.
But let's kind of start
where it always starts,
which is infrastructure.
And, in fact, let's start
at the edge with Windows.
Because when you step back,
the amount of compute there is
at the edge is actually
astounding, right?
I mean, think about every
NPU, GPU, CPU even, every PC.
If you sort of aggregate that,
that's a lot of compute power.
So we asked ourselves one
simple question, right?
If we can deliver unmetered
intelligence to every desk
and every home, right?
It takes us all the way
back to the very beginning.
But that's what we said.
Can we do that in
this era of AI?
And, in fact, we're,
in some sense,
delivering that
already today, right?
When you look at something
like, say, Outlook Summarize,
it's actually using
onboard AI locally.
Same thing with PowerPoint alt
text or Team Super Resolution.
It's just not Microsoft stuff.
For example, Adobe After Effects
or Premiere are both using
Windows ML across NPUs
and GPUs for local processing.
And so, today, one of the
things that I'm really excited
about in order to tap into
all this compute power is
to expand the scope of Windows
ML and Windows AI, right?
So you now have the
full install base
of GPUs that you can get to.
So I'm really thrilled
that every developer
out there can count on
building for local onboard AI
and then have it run across
all of the install base.
Now, we are also announcing
two very cool new models
that are all going to
run on Windows Inbox.
The first is a new SLM.
It's sort of a more efficient
model, Aion Instruct,
and it's a great
reasoning model.
And then we have the
planning model, Aion Plan,
which is a local agentic loop.
I mean, think about it, right?
You now have a full
local agentic loop.
You can give it tools access
and build fully onboard agentic
applications without having
to round trip to the cloud.
And of course, we said, in order
to really push the limits,
realize this unmetered
intelligence, there's also a lot
of hardware that's
evolving, too.
And so, we're thrilled
to see the innovation
across the Windows
ecosystem, right?
It's AMD with their
Ryzen processors.
The Panther Lake stuff from
Intel is just exciting to see.
Qualcomm announced two sets
of things which are great.
One on the high end with
Snapdragon X2 Elite.
And then on the low end,
even for sub-500 PCs
with Snapdragon C. So it's
great to see all of this.
And, of course, that brings
us to NVIDIA and RTX Spark.
This is a next-generation
SoC for PCs.
It brings together
the CPU, the GPU,
as well as the AI capabilities
into a single SoC.
And that's the exciting part.
And it includes unified
memory architecture
and also the integrated
DRTM, right?
So you now have all of
the systems innovation
and the SoC coming together.
And we're really thrilled
that one of the first devices
that we built was the
Surface Ultra, right?
It's a beautiful device.
And it really brings the
power of NVIDIA together
with the design and the
craftsmanship of Surface.
It's 128 gigabytes
of unified memory.
It's a beautiful
2,000-NIT display.
And it has an all-day
battery life.
And so, we are very excited
to see this later this fall.
And it's also wonderful
to see all the designs
from all the OEM partners who
are building, taking advantage
of this new SoC and the
new platform and bringing
out some pretty exciting
machines that are going
to be all available
come this fall.
And so, of course, we said,
okay, this is fantastic.
What can we do next?
So, we said, let's try and push
this and push the architecture
to its limit for
developers, right?
What if we could just max
the compute, max the memory,
build out that developer machine
that's the dream machine?
And that's what we're
announcing today.
Surface RTX Spark, Dev Box.
Let's roll the video.
[ Music ]
Satya Nadella:
All right.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, this is truly
a dream machine.
It's got one petaflop of
AI compute, 20 CPU cores.
All of those things
have 128 gigabytes
of unified memory access.
So super excited about
this coming in the fall
and you can join the waitlist.
I'm on the waitlist
as well, so --
[ Laughter ]
-- we'll get there.
You know, so then we
said, why stop there?
We said, what if we
did one more thing?
And in fact, I think
Jensen did that already.
And he said, Windows is
coming to the DGX station.
So a new, I describe it as
the desktop data center,
which you can have right there
and running a one-trillion
parameter model locally.
I mean, just to sort of
put it in perspective,
it's pretty close to
what perhaps we had
when we built
GPT-2.5 or 3, right,
one of the first supercomputers.
So it's pretty crazy to think
that we've come this far
where you can now have a
data center on your desktop.
And of course, we're extending
the developer endpoints even
to the cloud.
Windows 365 now has the
developer distribution that's
optimized for developer
productivity in the cloud.
So that's the Windows 365
that I use every day.
And it's simply about making
Windows, whether it's
on the laptop, the desktop,
the cloud, wherever --
the best place to build.
And so, to that end, we have tons
and tons of updates, right?
We're starting, by the way,
with one of the favorite things
for all of us, which
is distraction-free
dev environment.
We're also introducing
an intelligent terminal,
which has got built-in
GitHub Copilot, right?
Terminal with sort of the
Copilot intelligence.
And of course,
there's lots and lots
of Linux love
across Windows now.
So you have 70-plus utilities.
So GREP, in full glory,
is now available
for regular Windows access.
70-plus utilities, as I said,
all of that is
coming to Windows.
We're also bringing things
from the Mac that you love,
things like Starship, Z Shell.
Homebrew is going to be
native on Windows as well.
So you'll be able to
switch to Windows.
And today, we're
announcing WSL containers.
This has, I know,
been a point of pain
when you're managing
all these environments,
switching all the mental
gymnastics of trying
to keep this straight.
So having first-class support
for containers will really
help us be in the flow
when you are building
and deploying locally.
And to show you all of this
on our new Surface RTX Spark,
I wanted to invite up on stage
Kayla to just take a spin
through all the dev tools.
Kayla, go ahead.
[ Applause ]
Kayla Cinnamon: Our team
has been working hard
to make Windows a great
place for development.
And today, I'm going to show
you some major improvements
and delighters you
can try out today.
So what we have here is
the default experience
on the Surface RTX
Spark Dev Box.
Right away, it feels calm.
There's no news feed, no widgets
popping up, no notifications,
and of course,
we're in dark mode.
I'm immediately ready
to start development.
Well, there's one thing
I'd like to change.
I like to put my
taskbar on the left.
So let me jump into my taskbar
settings using the new Run,
which is built leveraging
the architecture
of PowerToys command pallet.
No, no, no, I want it
all the way on the left.
There we go.
After popular demand,
we're excited to announce
that vertical taskbar
is now available
in Windows Insider builds.
The new Surface RTX
Spark also has a bunch
of key dev tools already
installed, like Python, Node,
and many more of your favorites.
All of the developer
goodness, all in one file.
And if you want to get the same
experience today on your device,
we're making this file available
to everyone right now.
We have a public repo set up
with the configuration file
and instructions for how to
apply it using Winget Configure,
which will make the
adjustments to Windows
and install all the tools.
Now, one cool thing that I have
running here is PowerToys' new
utility called "Grab and Move",
which lets you hold "Alt"
and move the window
around from anywhere.
Another tip is that you
can enable "end task",
which lets you end the process
without having to
open Task Manager.
So let me jump
into my dev drive.
Dev drives run on REFS with
Defender running in async
and are optimized for
performance when it comes
to development scenarios.
Also, File Explorer
is "Git-aware".
We've got stuff like
"last change author name",
"last change message", the
status of each file.
Plus, my favorite is
that the branch name is
on the bottom left.
So now let's get started
building and open our terminal.
This is an experimental
experience called,
"Intelligent Terminal",
that makes working with
agents even more seamless.
When you first install
Intelligent Terminal,
you're greeted with the option
to pick your favorite agent.
I'm going to use GitHub
Copilot for today,
but you can use whichever
agent speaks to you.
Now here in
Intelligent Terminal,
I have a regular
terminal pane at the top
and an agent that's listening
on the bottom, and I can work
between them while the
agent helps along the way.
So for example, here's an
error being generated.
My agent pane is able to
detect it and provide a fix,
which is great when I
don't remember the syntax,
especially for
something like RegEX.
So I'm going to
work on OpenClaw,
and I've already built
it using WSL Container.
WSL Container is a native
container experience on Windows,
plus it can leverage the
GPU, which is perfect
for the Surface RTX Spark.
It can also reference your
existing container files,
just like the one in
the OpenClaw project.
So here's one of the files
open in Microsoft Edit,
which ships in
Windows by default
and just got syntax highlighting
in its latest version.
And then you can also just
see your containers running
with a simple container
images command.
And since we're on
the topic of WSL,
we're providing a WSL
profile that's designed
to feel comfortable for
those of you who use tools
like Starship,
Zsh, and Homebrew.
So it comes pre-configured with
all of your favorite utilities,
and it's available in the
repo that I showed earlier.
And it also includes one
of my favorites, BTOP.
So the Surface RTX
Spark is designed
for developer heavy workloads,
including serving large
local models for coding.
I've already done
some development
with a 120
billion-parameter model
that most machines
can't even load.
So here's a quick
view of my usage,
and we can see how many
tokens I've used locally.
So we're looking at about
3.4 million tokens leveraged
on the device itself.
Now, we can kick off multiple
sub-agents using Fleet.
And just so we don't
have to watch me type,
I'm going to use
Copilot's Voice feature,
which is also leveraging
its own local model.
So I'll just hold "Spacebar" and
tell it what I want it to do.
Find any console.writeline
or debug.writeline calls
in the tray and node
projects and convert them
to the standard logger used
elsewhere in the codebase.
There we go.
Now, the main agent will
delegate sub-agent tasks
of appropriate complexity to the
local model, utilizing my GPU
and making it more
cost efficient.
Now, as developers, while we're
debugging, we're often looking
through log files to
diagnose any issues.
Sometimes finding the location
of the log files is a challenge.
I'd love to be able to
just type something
like "grep log"
and find them all.
Ah, sweet.
So on top of already adding
curl, tar, and sudo to Windows,
now we're adding over 75
command-line
utilities like env, head,
tail, and touch for
those of us who love
to live in the terminal.
So I found all my log
files, but now having
to parse them is the
second challenge.
Well, I've actually had Aion
Instruct proactively performing
analyses on my log
files this whole time.
Now I can quickly diagnose
anything that's gone wrong
in my development, plus I don't
have to worry about token usage
because it's all local.
We can even take a look at
our machine's resources.
The models are loaded,
and you can see 90 gigs
of RAM being
utilized by the GPU,
truly showcasing the full power
of the Surface RTX Spark.
We were able to use three
local models simultaneously,
unmetered, while going
up our regular dev
flow without a hitch.
That's huge.
[ Applause ]
So, I know you're going to love
what the team's been working on.
We hope it gives you a
glimpse of what's possible
on Windows today and
where we're headed next.
Thank you.
Back to you, Satya.
[ Applause ]
Satya Nadella: Yeah, that's
really the beginning
of this idea of
unmetered intelligence,
having those models and having
the agents using the models work
in parallel to what
you may be doing along
with the cloud as well.
And that, I think, is what the
platform enables as first class.
Now let's move to the cloud.
You know, the driving equation
for us remains the same,
which is tokens per
dollar per watt.
How do we optimize
around this, right?
So when we think about
the systems problem,
we think about electrons
coming on one end and tokens
on the other end,
and how do we think
about the systems
optimization end-to-end?
It starts with the data
center design itself, right?
The core compute, storage,
network, all the accelerators
that go into accelerating
each of those components.
How do you even think about
the DC-to-DC connectivity
and the networking, as well
as the offload to something
like the local compute, right?
That's the sort of
systems challenge.
But before we even get
into all of the systems
and the technology
and the innovation,
perhaps the most
important design criteria
for us is, how do we earn the
permission from the communities
in which we're building
these data centers?
And that's where these
principles ground us
and focus us.
How do we ensure that the
DCs do not increase the
electricity prices?
Making sure that we are
replenishing all our water use,
creating jobs in the
local communities
for the local residents,
adding to the tax base,
making sure we are strengthening
the communities by investing
in local training and the
nonprofits in the area.
Only when we live up to these
principles, do the hard work
around it, is when we earn
the permission to go ahead
and innovate and build.
And we've been doing a lot
of data center build-out.
Today, Azure spans more than
500 data centers in 80 regions.
It's the most
expansive, you know,
we have the most expansive
hyperscaler footprint out there.
And we have added more
data center capacity
in the last 18 months than
the first decade of Azure,
just to put that in perspective.
But more importantly, what
we are building is also
very different.
In fact, the first 15
years or so, you know,
we built out the commercial
cloud infrastructure for a set
of heterogeneous, you know,
workloads that spanned
the enterprise.
But now when you look at
what we are building, right,
when you think about all the
gigawatts that were going
to come online, really, they
have three dominant workloads.
There is training,
there is inference,
and then there is the
agent runtime, right?
These are three
dominant workloads.
And in fact, when you
look at Fairwater,
it was sort of our
first AI super-factory.
You know, it spanned two
regions, Georgia and Wisconsin.
The entire system was designed
from the ground
up for AI, right?
We worked, in fact, very closely
with even NVIDIA on this.
It's a two-story architecture
that lets us essentially
place racks, obviously,
in three dimensions and
pack the maximum number
of GPUs densely with
network access.
That means you've really got
fantastic higher-performance
networking, lower latency,
and more effective bandwidth
across the entire cluster.
And we're rethinking even
the power delivery, right?
So we started, okay, how
do we deliver hundreds
of kilowatts per row while
minimizing all the loss, right,
which is the conversion
loss that happens
from the grid to the silicon.
So we basically sort of even
took a new approach to it.
And all of this also changes
with the cooling system,
right, and water.
So in fact, the cooling
loop is filled once,
and the data center can
operate effectively
with zero water consumption.
In fact, the daily water
usage over the course
of an entire year is
roughly equivalent
to what a single restaurant
would use, right?
I mean, that's --
[ Applause ]
And when it comes to the
systems and the silicon, again,
we have a lot of choice.
We have first-party silicon.
We have partner systems.
We were the very first
cloud to bring up, in fact,
NVIDIA's Vera Rubin
system for validation.
Very exciting to see that.
We're working closely with AMD.
We worked with them on MI300.
Now we're working with them on
their next-generation AMD GPUs.
Maia 200 is continuing to scale.
In fact, it's live
in Iowa and Arizona.
We'll deploy it internationally
later this year.
It delivers 30% improved tokens
per dollar compared to sort
of what's the leading GPU today.
And we have validated it with
5.5, GPT-5.5, and we are going
to use that to power
Microsoft 365 Copilot.
And so, when it comes to
running these agents,
the interesting thing now
is it's no longer just
about having an AI
accelerator or a GPU.
The CPU is really critical.
In fact, the ratios may be
even coming to one is to one.
And that's why we are
innovating with Cobalt.
We're announcing the
preview of Cobalt 200 VMs,
our next-generation
ARM-based CPU designed
for both cloud-native and
agent workloads today.
So it's exciting to see
Cobalt make progress as well.
[ Applause ]
You know, one thing that we've
been trying to make sure is
that it's being optimized
for these new workloads
I talked about, right?
These new agent workloads.
So in fact, Cobalt delivers
50-plus percent better
performance than Cobalt
100 on cloud-native.
But we started benchmarking them
using the GitHub Copilot traces,
these agentic traces,
to see because the call
patterns are so different.
And we're now seeing 33% lower
latency for the agent calls,
14% faster speed, 23%
higher throughput.
So this is about the core design
of both the AI accelerator
and the CPU for the agent.
And, of course, when you
talk about AI workloads,
you need scale, you
need reliability,
and that's why the network
becomes super critical.
We have innovated with
the MRC architecture
and rebuilt how traffic
across Azure moves
to support AI workloads,
which are fundamentally
synchronous data parallel
workloads, right?
And so, therefore, they span
tens and thousands of GPUs.
And so, you need to
have them coherent.
That's what the next
Frontier, you know,
is for us to make
sure we're able
to keep scaling the
network architecture.
And, of course, it's not about
just inside the data center.
It's also about connecting
across the data centers.
And every Fairwater data center,
for example, is connected
through our
continent-spanning AI Wan
forming this truly
fungible compute fabric.
And, you know, all this
innovation is exciting,
but when you think about
innovation, designing for AI,
and I would say, deep
understanding of systems,
you know, there's no better
company than NVIDIA,
and there's no better person
than Jensen to talk about it.
So I want to invite, live
from Taipei, Jensen Huang,
CEO and founder of NVIDIA.
[ Applause ]
Jensen Huang: Hi, Satya.
Satya Nadella: Thank you so
much for being at Build again.
I know it's late
for you in Taipei.
I really appreciate
you staying up.
You know, I've been looking
at social and, you know,
and everything people
have been talking
about since your keynote
over the weekend.
And suddenly, you
know, this concept
of unmetered intelligence right
at the edge is so hot again.
So maybe you want to
talk a little bit.
You have thought about this,
talked about this, and now,
of course, with RTX Spark
really delivered, I think,
what's a breakthrough system for
AI to be much more ubiquitous.
But maybe, Jensen, you can just
share a little bit your vision
around where you see this going.
Jensen Huang: Well, this all
started about three years ago
between a conversation
between you and I.
And we were talking about how
we could build a new class
of PCs that's incredible
for designers and creators,
and it would be incredible
for artificial intelligence.
And it would be one
of these systems
that has the
processing capability
but also the software
stack that's integrated
into the world's design packages
and creator packages and,
of course, all the things
that we're doing with AI.
And here we are,
three years later,
we built an incredible new chip,
and this system is supported
by all of this new software
that you created for Windows.
And we now have the ability
to have, essentially,
an autonomous agent
running on the PC.
Now, when you take a step
back and you think about
what does that mean?
For the 40 years
or some 30 years
we've been working together,
we went from inventing
DirectX together
to creating now this
incredible computer
that has autonomous
systems running.
The PC evolved from
being an incredible tool
to now being a tool that's used
autonomously by an AI assistant.
And so, the idea that I could be
traveling and I'm on the phone
and I could text my PC and ask
my PC to get some coding done
or some idea that I
have, and it would fire
up the tools on the PC.
And it would make the
modifications or the changes
or the design that I told it
to do, and it would iterate
with me while I'm
away from the PC.
My PC became an assistant.
While I'm sitting
there, of course,
this PC would be my
great assistant as well.
And so, this idea that the PC
evolved from a personal computer
to a personal AI, it's
just really exciting.
And to see it come to life,
Satya, to see it come to life
and actually doing
that, you know,
so I'm super excited about it.
Spark, as you mentioned earlier,
has all this incredible
capabilities,
a petaflop of AI performance.
It has a petaflop of NVFP4,
this numerical format
that our two companies worked
on together that allows us
to take advantage of this
128 gigabytes of memory
and fit maybe a couple of
hundred-billion-parameter model.
A couple
of hundred-billion-parameter
model is state-of-the-art.
And so, I think the days
of having a really smart
assistant running autonomously
on the PC is here.
Satya Nadella: Yeah,
no, it's so awesome.
And in fact, I'm also excited
about Windows coming
to the GB300.
And so, that's another
thing that it's kind
of like data center
right on your desktop.
And it's so exciting.
But talking about that data
center side, obviously,
you know, this entire
thing got started
when we built the first
supercomputer together
to train the GPT models.
And we have come a long way.
In fact, even I was talking
about the Fairwater design,
it is custom-built essentially
for the Grace Blackwell era
to be able to max the
data center design
with the system design you had.
And now, of course, we're
validating Vera Rubin.
We're very excited about it.
Maybe you want to share
a little bit about sort
of what happens even
on the cloud side
with how you're pushing on
the systems innovation.
Jensen Huang: Well, our
journey is incredible.
We built the first AI
supercomputer together.
That was based on Ampere.
Of course, Hopper was
an incredible success.
Those first two generations
were focused on pre-training.
Grace Blackwell came along
and all of the focus moved
to post-training reinforcement
learning, which allowed us
to have reasoning models.
And these reasoning models,
based on mixture of experts,
were incredibly intelligent,
energy efficient.
But it requires giant systems.
And so, we created NVLink 72,
and the entire rack
became one computer.
We had evolved from one
node to now one rack.
Well. . .
Microsoft deployed
the largest number
of Grace Blackwells in the
world today; the fastest
and the largest number of
Grace Blackwells in the world.
Fairwater is just a
magnificent system to look at.
It's just a miracle
of engineering.
It's just an incredible feat.
It's completely liquid-cooled.
You mentioned something earlier
that I'm very proud of as well,
that it's closed looped,
basically uses almost no water.
And it's incredibly
environmentally friendly.
It's energy efficient.
We're able to increase
the token generation rate
and reduce the cost of token
generation by an order
of magnitude, some 30
times over Hopper.
So that was a huge achievement.
Well, Vera Rubin was
created for a world
where these AIs are now agentic.
And so, whereas Hopper was
created for pre-training,
Grace Blackwell for
training, post-training,
and also inference, Vera Rubin
is designed to run agents.
It's agents, as you know,
this computing pattern is
exactly the same computing
pattern we're going to
run on the RTX Spark.
It's exactly the same agentic
system, except, of course,
it's going to be
much, much larger.
We're going to process
an enormous number
of them simultaneously.
Many of them are going to
be from different customers
and different partners.
And so, the entire path, the
entire coding path from storage,
which is the long-term memory,
the working memory,
is encrypted.
The data is encrypted
in transit.
The data is also
encrypted in use.
And so, we're going to
really innovate in the area
of confidential computing.
And so, this entire
disaggregated,
distributed computing
system, you mentioned CPUs.
Vera is a revolutionary
CPU designed for agents.
You know, the past CPUs
were designed for humans.
And, you know, we're just
more patient than agents are.
And agents want low latency,
just as you've been
working on as well.
Vera was designed for
extremely low latency.
And so, Vera Rubin is just
completely revolutionary.
I can't wait to show
it to everybody.
You've already stood it up.
Satya Nadella: Yep.
Jensen Huang:
Our two teams
have been working very closely.
You know, almost long
before the chips taped out,
long before the systems
were brought up,
our two teams were already
completely aligned.
And so, the design, the
data centers were created
for Vera Rubin.
Vera Rubin is designed
and integrated
into your complete stack,
into your networking,
into your security.
And so, the moment that our
systems were rolling off the
lines, they were being
stood up at Microsoft.
So I'm incredibly excited
about the collaboration.
Satya Nadella: Yeah, I know
this speed of light execution
between the teams is
fantastic to see.
And, of course, all this is
to power the ecosystem
around us, right?
I mean, you and I, having grown
up with the PC, the server,
and now with AI, have always
thought about, ultimately, it's
about creating the opportunity
for every developer,
every organization to build
on the work that we do
and the platforms we create.
And speaking of that,
there's a lot of software
that NVIDIA builds
that's all also coming.
For example, we're going to
have your models in Foundry,
your tooling in Foundry.
We're going to have, in fact,
your software even help us
with accelerating our
workloads when it comes
to even the data warehouse.
We're going to obviously
have stuff in Windows.
Just talk a little bit
about that broader vision
of what does it mean for --
as an opportunity, right?
Because everybody talks
about this one model
or one piece of tech.
But it's about the broadest,
biggest opportunity
for people to create value.
Maybe you want to share a
little bit about that.
Jensen Huang: Well, we've been
preparing for this moment.
You know, what happened in
the last several months,
we've been working for a
decade and a half together,
getting ready for,
really, what happened
in the last several months.
All of a sudden, because of
agentic systems, the convergence
of these really great
models, AI is now useful.
If you just look at GitHub,
the commits into GitHub has
gone completely parabolic.
In the last several months,
the number of commits increased
by a factor of three.
It's clear that agentic
systems are useful,
that it's doing productive work,
and also tokens are now
profitable as a result.
And so, the amount of demand
for compute between the usage
of the AI and the computation
that's necessary for agents,
the compute demand has really
gone through the roof.
Well, one of the things
that we've been doing together
is making sure that all
of the tools that
agents are going
to use are fully accelerated.
Fabric, for example, is
now fully accelerated.
We're accelerating data
processing, SQL, Spark,
semantic-based,
vector-based, graph-based.
We're going to make sure
that all of the tools
that are available
on Azure are going
to be fully GPU-accelerated
because the agents are
going to be impatient.
The faster we can get the
answers back to the agents,
the faster they can iterate, the
faster we can generate tokens,
which are ultimately
what the developers,
both of our customers would
like to do, is generate a lot
of tokens that are
really profitable,
that are highly intelligent.
Satya Nadella: Thank
you so much, Jensen,
for the partnership and the
leadership and the innovation
that you bring to this
entire ecosystem.
And really thrilled to be
working closely with you
and the team and bring all
this to the developers here
and beyond and look forward
to seeing what the next sort
of few months and the next year
bring in terms of the innovation
that gets built on
top of the platform.
So thank you again
for joining this late
in the night from Taipei.
Jensen Huang:
Thank you so much, Satya,
for your partnership and
friendship. Thank you.
Satya Nadella:
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Satya Nadella: So so
far, we've talked
about the edge and the cloud.
The current form factors, right?
I mean, when I saw that Jensen
picture from the weekend
where he had all the
desktops, I felt like, man,
I'm back in the '90s, right?
Because it is so cool to see
the lineup of all the machines
that I loved and I grew
up with back yet again
with new functionality, right?
The same form factor, but
unbelievable new functionality
because of the onboard
AI capability, right?
So that's sort of what
we've seen with the laptop,
the desktop and, of
course, with the cloud.
But it also, you know, sets
up that next question.
If you have that capability,
which is new function
and you can put it into
existing form factors,
can you even purpose-build
new form factors
for the new function?
Can you build a new platform
even for the agent era?
And that is the motivation
behind Project Solara,
which we're introducing today.
And to talk about this, I wanted
to invite Stevie on stage.
But first, let's roll the video.
Speaker 1: First, there's you.
[ Music ]
Then, everything
in front of you.
[ Music ]
We get it.
The noise.
The weight of it all.
[ Music ]
So we've been
building something.
[ Music ]
A new
chip-to-cloud platform
for an agent-first world.
And for new agent first devices.
You come close.
It's ready when you are.
You speak.
It understands you.
What matters comes forward.
Everything else falls away.
And when you want it to
keep going, it keeps going.
Your call.
Sometimes it sits with you.
Sometimes it goes with you.
Sometimes it sees what
you want it to see.
It doesn't decide for you.
It just lights the path.
It tries to clear the
way when you need it to.
And that's the idea.
A whole ecosystem built
to clear the way.
So all that's left is
where you need to go.
Wherever you are.
Whenever it matters.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Steven Bathiche: I am
so excited to be here.
It really is great to
be back on this stage.
Now, before I talk about those
awesome new devices you just
saw, let me start
with the "why".
Back at Build 2023, I talked
about the outside AI application
structure, where AI moves
from operating within
the application frame
to operating globally,
working across multiple apps
and services to connect,
coordinate and maintain context
across entire workflows,
devices and time scales.
What if there were an ecosystem
of devices specifically designed
for that new type of application
structure, for those types
of agents, for that
transformational
interaction technology?
That is the impetus
behind Project Solara.
But with so many possible
forms, which one do you pick?
What is the next device?
You see, the big "a-ha"
for us is that it's not
about choosing one
specific form factor,
it is about creating a system
that extends your agent
across a constellation
of devices.
The next computer
is not one device.
It is all these devices working
together as one system,
with agents showing up closer to
where and when you need them.
To realize this vision, two
challenges immediately show up.
First, many specialized
form factors already exist,
but often rely on custom one-off
apps and fragmented stacks
that are difficult and expensive
to build, deploy and maintain.
And second, across
every industry,
people and organizations are
already building their own
agents, deeply specialized and
instrumented for their work.
But the impact of those
agents is constrained by how
and where they can exist.
Project Solara addresses both
by giving organizations a way
to extend their agents
onto new, purpose-built,
easy-to-manage form factors
designed to reach the nooks
and crannies where conventional
computers either do not exist
or are not optimal.
It's a turnkey solution
for building unique
agent-first devices enabled
by three pillars.
First, it's enterprise-ready,
enabled by the AOSP-based
Microsoft device
ecosystem platform.
Second, it has an agent-driven
interaction model
with just-in-time UI that
adapts to the form factor.
And third, it has extensibility
so you can bring
your own agents.
And tying it all together is
Azure, unifying the system
across cloud and device.
Okay. That's enough of that.
Now let's talk
about the devices.
Today we're previewing two
very broad categories.
The first is stationary and
the second is portable.
The first device is
designed for your desk
and it's built on
MediaTek silicon.
With Hello for
Business, just walking
up to the device securely signs
you in, giving you direct access
to your agents, just like
Nathan's about to show you here.
For the information worker,
this means frictionless
yet protected access
to Microsoft 365 Copilot
grounded in Work IQ.
And with a simple glance, it
surfaces what matters next
in your workday, helping you
think, plan, and even act
by delegating tasks to your
agents with a simple tap
or just using your voice.
Think of it as a
dedicated, secured,
ambient device for work.
It even supports experiences
like handoff between devices,
acting as a companion to
your existing Windows PC.
Or, it can even let you
access your cloud PC
through Windows 365 and
a connected monitor.
How cool is that?
[ Cheering ]
[ Applause ]
Now, the second
device is portable.
It's reimagining a
wearable that millions
of people use every
day, the access badge.
Built using Qualcomm
silicon for wearable,
this digital badge is a
lightweight form factor designed
for agent interactions
on the go.
And then it's adaptable
across a variety
of verticals and workflows.
All right, I have here an
early prototype of the badge.
And so -- thanks.
And using my fingerprint, I
tap to unlock the device.
And I have access now to all
my agents in a secured manner.
And would you look at that?
I already have a task.
And it says gather content
for your social media
posts for today.
So, why not just do
it right now, right?
So, I'm going to hit "Record".
And then now the device's
camera is recording.
I'm going to pan across.
I hope you don't mind.
I'm going to take your shots.
Yes. Thank you.
Copilot, find some good shots
from this, clean them up,
and then send them to me for
me and my team to review.
All right.
And then there you have it.
Now my agent's off running
through multiple tasks
to actually clean this up and
send them to me and the team.
That's pretty cool.
[ Applause ]
Okay, I know it's a simple demo,
but it's all agent-driven.
And there are so many verticals,
so many opportunities.
I mean, for example,
imagine in healthcare.
From the moment you
pick up the device,
the right agent shapes the
experience around the role
and the workflow, helping with
check-ins, patient records,
and critical insights,
all through enterprise-grade
secure access.
And with the built-in
microphones,
the nurse can start a hands-free
voice-based documentation,
including diarization
and annotation.
And the side-facing camera
can be used to verify
and document patient vitals
or even scan in medications
and help verify workflows.
You know, these are
just a few examples
of how this small purpose-built
wearable can bring intelligence
directly into the
flow of patient care,
helping nurses access
and gather and even act
on information while staying
present with the patient.
And while both the stationary
and portable concept devices
represent a specific expression
of agent-first devices, their
core reference hardware
and software are designed
to be highly flexible.
I mean, just with a few changes,
loading a different agent,
adjusting the shape, the
screen size, the sensors,
or even input methods,
the same foundation,
the same software can be
adapted for many verticals
and workflows, such as retail,
industrial, hospitality,
financial service,
legal, and so forth.
I mean, that is the power of
the platform, that flexibility.
So whatever your scenario,
there are thousands
of untapped opportunities
to bring agent workflows
into places where computing
has not naturally fit before.
And while this is an early
look, we're really excited
that AccuWeather, Best Buy,
CBS Health, Levi's, Target,
and others are working towards
exploring how specialized agents
and devices can improve
their workflows.
This is the broader
opportunity for the ecosystem.
Agents moving outside
the app and taking shape
in devices designed for
a specific scenario,
a specific customer,
and a specific place.
And for all of you, this
is the moment to imagine
where your agents should live,
what form they should take,
and what new work
they can unlock.
Last week, Satya sat down with
Cristiano Amon from Qualcomm
to discuss this future.
Let's roll the video.
Satya Nadella:
Cristiano, it's so wonderful
having you here at
Device Lab and to talk
about these new
reference designs.
Cristiano Amon: Very
happy to be here.
I have been to this Device
Lab a lot recently.
Satya Nadella: You know,
one of the things that you
and I have chatted
for a while is,
how there's a real
platform shift.
We are moving from building
operating systems,
devices for apps to agents.
You want to talk a little
bit about how you see this?
Cristiano Amon: Yeah,
absolutely. In every generation
of technology transition
we've seen a shift,
and I think this one seems
to be a very big one.
Agents really changes the whole
nature of the device in itself,
starting with the
fact that, you know,
if the AI understand the world
the way we understand it,
it's going to be
closer to our senses.
It's going to be closer to our
eyes, to our mouth, to our ears.
It's going to be
things that we wear,
and it's changing the
nature of the computing.
I think you need a computing
that is now geared
towards real-time context
and from silicon to cloud.
Satya Nadella: I mean,
this is sort of one
of the reference designs
we have, which I love.
There's stuff happening at
the edge here on this device.
There's things on the cloud.
You want to talk a little
bit about the core systems
and silicon implications
for such a new ecosystem?
Cristiano Amon: You need a
very power-efficient CPU.
The whole silicon
is designed for you
to have a cloud-native
experience.
And then you have
a lot of sensors.
Satya Nadella: Right.
Cristiano Amon: A lot
of sensors for context.
It's a much more personalized
and bespoke experience
than an app in itself.
And I think that's changing
the nature of devices.
And even the definition
of a wearable platform
is changing in itself.
And you've started to see those
incredible new form factors.
Satya Nadella: That computing
platform, one of the things
that you and I have talked a lot
about is, how do you build it
such that there is an
open ecosystem, right?
Because it's not
about one agent.
It's about any agent.
Cristiano Amon: This
is what makes it very,
very interesting and exciting.
Because the smartphone
today is at the center
of your digital life, the job
of those devices today is
to be extending the
functionality of the smartphone.
And because of that, you
actually saw that many
of those platforms
became vertical.
It was a natural thing to
have a vertical platform
from the same company because
the phone was at the center.
That changes dramatically --
Satya Nadella:
Right.
Cristiano Amon:
-- when you think about agents.
And agents becomes the center
of your digital experience.
And the industry is
going to be looking
for an open horizontal platform
that actually enable the agents
to be interacting with
the best possible device
for different applications.
And I think that's
what's exciting.
Satya Nadella: And we
want to make it possible
for anybody who's thinking
of an agentic system
to not just be bound to current
devices, but to imagine
that there can be many,
many devices that carry
that intelligence in different
contexts. And so, that's
the open ecosystem
we want to build together.
And again, it's so
great to be partnered
with you to get this started.
Cristiano Amon: That's awesome.
We're very proud of
this partnership.
And it's just the beginning.
[ Applause ]
Satya Nadella: Thank you very
much, Stevie and Cristiano.
We are very excited
about Project Solara.
It's sort of a new
platform, but perhaps,
more importantly, it's a
set of new platform rules
that don't, you
know, in some sense,
hem in what you can imagine,
the type of form factors,
where your agents live.
I think always whenever these
new platforms have come,
you get to rewrite
even the rules
of how new platforms operate.
And that's what we are trying
to get done with Project Solara
so that you as developers and
enterprises have the flexibility
to imagine the form
factors that you want
and have your agents
be ubiquitous.
Now, let's go up the
stack to the next layer.
We are building a new
intelligence layer,
bringing together the models,
context, as well as the tools.
It, of course, starts
with model choice.
Every customer, every
developer is going
to choose the right
model for the right task
and their eval mix, latency
budget, even COGS budgets.
And Foundry, today, has
over 11,000 models.
It's the largest model
catalog out there from OpenAI
to Anthropic and, of
course, even MAI models.
And just last week, we brought
the OpenAI real-time voice
models along with Claude
Opus 4.8 to Foundry.
So we're continuing to bring
all theseFrontier models.
The consideration, though,
about the models is becoming
now increasingly key.
In fact, from the last
developer conference to now,
when you're building
any agentic system,
having this context really
shaped right is becoming
super important.
And, in fact, it starts right
at the data tier, right?
The data estate to date has
been built for applications
that supported these user-facing
applications, right?
Now you have to change and build
them for agents, which, again,
have very different call
patterns even to the data tier.
Agents are continuously
storing, retrieving, reasoning,
acting, and learning, right?
That's sort of what's happening
in a continuous loop.
And you see that today.
Agents are using things like
Cosmos DB for their memory.
In fact, ChatGPT does.
Azure Search is
used for retrieval
of indices and embeddings.
Fabric IQ for the
semantic models
and the ontologies instead
of the business logic tier
effectively for agents.
And also, you have Fabric
real-time intelligence
for all the observability
traces, which now brings me
to a very exciting new
service, Horizon DB,
which is our fully managed
PostgreSQL service on Azure.
Really thrilled to have this.
[ Applause ]
I mean, one of the things we
wanted to make sure is we built,
ground-up, a Postgres
managed service which was
for high availability scale-out.
It's zoned-redundant
with automated failover,
128 terabytes of storage per
cluster, 15 read replicas.
I mean, the read-heavy
workloads you can scale
with this managed service.
And in our internal testing,
we're seeing something like,
you know, Horizon is delivering
3x throughput compared
to any self-managed
Postgres SQL setup.
So it's super critical when you
think about the scale you need.
The other data workload
we're also changing pretty
dramatically is the
data warehouse.
In a world where agents are
constantly querying data,
the data warehouse effectively
becomes pretty mission critical,
right?
I mean, it's one thing to
have it be mission critical
for users, but when agents need
the analysis done on the fly,
you know, bringing
GPU acceleration
to Fabric is super key, and we
are seeing 7x performance gains.
So it's really thrilling to
see that AI acceleration.
[ Applause ]
So if you sort of
have the data tier,
the layer about this is the
IQ layer that we are building
that brings
together, essentially,
the model capabilities
along with the data, right?
So you kind of mix the data
and the model capabilities
so that you can deliver
that right context
to unlock intelligence, right?
That's where -- in fact, if
you want, when people talk
about token efficiency, this
is perhaps the most important
consideration, right?
If you structure the context
right and feed the models,
then you will, by definition,
going to be so much
more token-efficient.
The first domain is the web.
Web grounding is so important.
You need that fresh,
high-quality and fast web data,
and that's why we are
really, really excited
to announce today Web IQ.
[ Applause ]
And Web IQ is built
on our global infrastructure
that's already serving
over a billion users, but
fundamentally re-architected
for the LLM and the
agentic workflow.
It's model-agnostic,
it's MCP-native,
plugs right into
any agent runtime.
It has web, it has
news, images, video,
so agents can ground responses
in fresh, verifiable content.
And Web IQ leads across all of
the three key criteria, right?
It's best-in-class in
quality, it's best in class
in speed, as well as in cost.
So we're very, very
thrilled about Web IQ being
in the developers' hands as
you build out agentic systems.
Of course, we're
not stopping there.
Beyond the web, every
developer wants to be able
to ground their agents on
what's the most valuable data
across the enterprise.
And so, we are bringing
together Foundry, Fabric,
and Microsoft 365 as this
unified IQ layer, right?
It's a continuously
updated understanding
of your organization to show you
all of this rich IQ in action,
building real-life agents.
Here is Elijah.
Elijah, take it away.
[ Applause ]
Elijah Straight: Agents
are only as good
as the context we give them.
Microsoft IQ unifies
enterprise intelligence
for every organization.
I'm here at a Power Utilities
Control Center and will start
by running a long-running agent.
This agent is going to help
us assess the current grid
operations incident and
produce a brief for us
so we can respond accordingly.
Now, I'm going to go
ahead and kick that off.
And while that runs, let me
show you how we got here
with context from Microsoft IQ.
We built our agent in
Microsoft Foundry.
It's connected to various
tools, and it's also wired
to a Foundry IQ knowledge
base, a single grounded source
that packages our documents,
operational data,
and people into context
the agent can reason over.
After building the agent in
Foundry, we published it
to Microsoft 365
for the whole team.
Let's go see it in action.
Now, here in M365, I will
start with a question
about current events that an
ungrounded LLM wouldn't be able
to answer.
I'm going to ask about current
electricity prices in SF.
For this, our agent pulls in the
first IQ in our toolbox, Web IQ,
search built for the AI era.
Web IQ delivers
industry-leading quality,
velocity, and efficiency.
Web IQ constantly indexes
fresh, official sources
from across the web,
and additionally,
Web IQ does a great job
with semantic documents.
And here we can see Web IQ
gave us our answer grounded
in reality.
Now, not only can we deploy
our agent here in M365,
but we can also embed
it in our custom apps.
Let's head back to
the control center.
Let's see how we handled
a previous incident.
So, after using Web IQ to
gather external info,
we asked for details about our
potentially at-risk substations.
The real power of Microsoft
IQ comes when we combine
that external knowledge with our
own internal enterprise context.
For this information, our
agent pulls in the next layer
of Microsoft IQ, Fabric IQ.
Here is Brightline's
grid represented
as a Fabric ontology,
an operational model
of the live grid.
And critically, we didn't
build this from scratch.
Fabric takes the Power BI
semantic models used by millions
of customers today and
lets teams extend them
into rich ontologies that
help run the business.
This model -- yes!
This model is coupled
with live telemetry
so it reflects the
real operational state
of the grid minute-by-minute.
This is what Microsoft IQ means
by enterprise intelligence.
[ Applause ]
Not data scattered across
disparate systems,
but a single living
model of the business
that an agent can reason over.
Now, turning back to our agent,
we can see that it
gave us a table
of our most exposed substations.
That's the agent querying
the ontology you just saw.
Now, the agent has access
to both the outside
world and our grid.
The last piece is the one
that turns a situation
into a response, our
policies and our people.
By asking, what are the steps to
respond to a substation trip,
we activate the final layer
of Microsoft IQ, Work IQ.
This is Brightline's response
procedure in SharePoint.
It's the playbook the
team actually reaches
for when something goes wrong.
And the important thing is,
the agent isn't working
from a stale upload
or copied snapshot.
It's answering from the same
source the team maintains day
to day.
When the procedure changes,
the answer changes with it.
No re-uploads, no prompt
rebuilds, and no stale versions.
And critically, this
is your knowledge.
The assets you create stay
with you, no matter what model
or agent is reasoning over them.
Now, if we return to our agent,
we can see the proper way
to respond to this issue.
Not a generic recommendation,
but our playbook applied
to this incident.
Now, we just saw one
situation, three questions,
and one connected answer.
Now, let's go check back in
on our long-running agent.
And, oh, let's check the
backup really quick.
Moment of truth. . .
And. . .
boom!
Our task finished.
[ Applause ]
Here we can see every
step the agent took.
First, beginning with Web IQ,
connecting it to
the outside world.
Second, Fabric IQ through
Foundry, anchoring it
in the real state
of our operations.
And third, Work IQ, grounding it
in our people and procedures.
I triggered this manually,
but with Foundry routines,
this can run on a schedule,
turning a one-off response
into continuous
proactive execution.
And, if we look closely, we
can see it even used the power
of Work IQ to alert me
directly about the incident.
And if we go ahead
and check Teams,
it sent me an incident brief
notifying me of the situation.
[ Applause ]
That's the power
of Microsoft IQ.
When a crisis hits, the
team doesn't chase answers
across a dozen systems.
They ask a question and get a
response grounded in the world,
their operations,
and their people,
all in one place they can trust.
Back to you, Satya.
[ Applause ]
Satya Nadella: All right.
Thank you, Elijah.
And now, you know,
let's sort of move
up from this context model
layer to deploying these agents
and thinking about the runtime.
And, you know, when you're
building a first-class agentic
system, you need a first-class
agent runtime and a platform
that we are going to ship
both with Windows as well
as part of Foundry in Azure.
We want Windows to
be a fantastic place
to run and scale agents.
And agents, effectively,
are a new execution
environment, right?
It's a new paradigm even.
They reason continuously.
They generate and run
code dynamically.
They take actions across
files and devices as well
as across the network.
Obviously, there's a lot
of power in it, right?
The fact that it can
generate code and act on it
on a long-running agent
that's autonomous.
But, obviously, it
creates new risk.
And that's why today we're
introducing Microsoft Execution
Containers, or MXC.
MXC is a new policy layer that
lets Windows apply isolation
and containment
using AI-native --
-- or OS-native
primitives, right?
You need to bake this
into the operating system
so that the containment
is enforced by policy.
You can have
process-level isolation
for lightweight agent actions.
You can have session-level
isolation for user separation.
So Windows and Linux
virtual machines, in fact,
are also great, including WSL,
for much stronger boundaries.
And, in fact, if you want full
isolation and containment,
Windows 365 for agents
for maximum isolation
in a separate managed
environment effectively.
You can pick the right
containment option
for the workload, and Windows
will enforce it via MXC.
And so, I think this becomes
pretty critical as you think
about deploying agents at
scale on your Windows desktop.
We want to ensure containment
is enforced, of course,
regardless of who builds
the agent, right?
So this is why you want to bake
it into the operating system.
To that end, we are working
with many partners to ensure
that containment, we
are building support,
real developer
workloads out there,
and also addresses the needs.
In fact, NVIDIA is bringing
OpenShell to Windows
to securely execute
autonomous AI agents.
And today, we are really
thrilled to announce
that OpenClaw runs on
Windows, leveraging MXC.
[ Applause ]
Yeah, we are very deeply
engaged with the team
to make OpenClaw run
super well on Windows.
And so, let me hand it
over to my colleagues,
Scott and Samantha, to show
you OpenClaw on Windows.
Scott, Samantha.
[ Applause ]
Scott Hanselman: Hey, friends.
You know, OpenClaw came out
in November of last year,
and it took the world by storm.
And for the last several months,
I've been reusing my OpenClaw
to stay on top of my health.
My "claw" can help me
manage my blood sugar,
and it gives me even proactive
notifications via "heartbeat".
I've got mine triaging
my personal email,
it's doing my GitHub issues
and tracking packages,
and it even buys
me movie tickets.
So, Samantha, what are
you using your "claw" for?
Samantha Song:
That's cool, Scott.
I turned my OpenClaw agent
into my triathlon coach.
I'm nowhere near ready
for my race in September,
but Coach "Claw" developed
a work-back plan for me
and is using my Strava data to
notify me on how I'm progressing
and to keep me accountable
when I'm slacking.
Scott Hanselman: Now,
we've both found our "claws"
to be super useful, and that's
why we're working closely
with OpenClaw to
make them successful
and even more
successful on Windows.
We've been collaborating
in the open on GitHub
to bring you all an OpenClaw
Windows Companion app.
It's going to help you set
up your own "claws" or connect
to existing ones,
whether they're hosted
in Windows or in WSL.
And the Windows Companion,
we're going to sandbox
the OpenClaw tool calls
to keep you and
your system safe.
Samantha Song: Yeah,
you'll see the OpenClaw Windows
Companion app running right now
in the background.
Go ahead and right-click
on it, Scott.
Scott Hanselman:
All right. . .
Samantha Song: That
looks awesome.
You'll notice
immediately it looks
like a native Windows
app because it is.
It's written in WinUI 3.
It's got all kinds of
information about my Gateway,
other machines that are
participating in my "claw",
my sessions, and my usage.
I've also got quick access
to things like Chat, Canvas,
the main dashboard, and more.
Let's jump into
companion settings.
Within the app, we've got full
chat support with tool calling.
And you'll notice down here
in the corner, we've got lots
of permissions options along
with our sandbox configuration.
Scott Hanselman: Now, this
sandbox is really interesting
because this is using MXC, the
Microsoft Execution Containers.
And for this, we're going to
be using process isolation.
Now, newer versions
of Windows are going
to have even more
containment options,
so you're going to want to
keep an eye out for more news
with MXC in the future.
Now, I can see that I've
got "One-click" security
option settings.
But, Samantha, talk to
me about "Custom folders".
Samantha Song: Yeah,
you've got full support
about what files and folders you
want OpenClaw to have access to.
And really granular security
features like "Clipboard" access
or talking to the
Internet itself.
Now, I've given it
read-only desktop,
read access to your
desktop folder.
OpenClaw already has
a rich safety layer.
And that layer is only augmented
more by appropriate containment
that can be managed by me
or policies applied by IT.
Now, for the purposes
of this demo,
I'm going to do something
really scary and ask OpenClaw
to delete all the
files on your desktop.
Scott Hanselman: That's cool,
because I have a
nice, clean desktop.
I think you're keeping a secret.
You hid all your icons from the
audience while we were on stage.
I think we need to show the
audience who you really are.
Samantha Song: So disrespectful.
I know where everything is.
[ Laughter ]
It's just -- don't
touch my stuff.
I know where they are.
You know, Sam, I need to
make sure that you're clear
that a messy desktop
is an organized mind.
I'm pretty sure that
that's the quote, right?
So what we've done is
we've asked OpenClaw
to delete those files
from the Windows node.
And the only thing that is going
to keep from happening is MXC,
because we've turned off all
of the many layers
that OpenClaw offers.
But our IT -- in this
case, Samantha --
has set it to read-only.
So, it's trying to go and
delete all of those files.
We can actually see the
different attempts,
where it's going and deleting,
and then checking the directory,
and then deleting again,
because it's very persistent.
It wants these files gone,
and I want them to stay.
Oh, nope. The read-only
sandbox is there.
94 JPEGs are still
on the desktop.
Absolutely.
My desktop icons are safe from
Samantha's reign of terror.
Foiled again.
Scott Hanselman:
Oh, my goodness -- so bad.
Samantha Song: Today we've
seen security sandboxing,
WinUI 3, and open-source
brought together all
in this alpha release of
a Windows companion app.
We think this app is a great
opportunity to showcase OpenClaw
on Windows, and it's only going
to get better in
the coming months.
Scott Hanselman: That is
right, and by the way,
I want to note that we're doing
all this development work
on this calm Windows development
machine with all the tools
that I love, like WSL,
Containers, and Containment,
and I've even got GitHub Copilot
with multi-model
support ready to go.
Now, this is literally how the
team and I have been working
on the OpenClaw app on GitHub.
Now, people might wonder how
all of this came together.
Turns out, that
over the holidays,
I got a DM from this random
guy on the Internet,
and it took me a couple of
days to get back to him,
and then when I did, we just
had this kind of cool idea
that maybe he should
come to Microsoft Build.
Now, I think there's one more
person that we all want to thank
for bringing the next generation
of agents to the world.
Everybody put your
hands together
for the "Clawfather" himself,
Peter Steinberger.
[ Applause ]
Peter Steinberger:
Scott. . .
Samantha.
Stop showing off my secret DMs.
[ Laughter ]
I'm so excited to see
OpenClaw native on Windows.
You know, watching a "claw" try
to delete all your desktop file
and just fail made
me really happy
[ Laughter ]
because six months ago,
that totally would have worked.
[ Laughter ]
You know, I built OpenClaw to
have access to everything.
You know, my files, my
machines, my chats, always on
and fully open-source.
That's what makes
it so powerful,
and that's what also makes
companies a bit nervous.
You know, what I
kept hearing was,
"Peter, I love my 'claw',
can I use this at work?"
And that's what we spent
the last few months on,
with Microsoft, GitHub, OpenAI,
NVIDIA, just to name a few.
We added observability.
We added auto mode
for permissions.
We changed how access works.
It's not all or nothing anymore.
You can pick which folder
should be read-only,
which one should be
write-it or hidden.
So here's the news.
You can totally run OpenClaw
inside your company now.
[ Cheering ]
[ Applause ]
And we even made the
harness itself a plug-in.
You can bring your own.
Copilot, Codex, whatever
you already trust,
and your rules come
right with it.
And then you put
OpenClaw on top of it.
You get persistent
memory, heartbeats,
and you get a "claw" right
inside Slack or Teams.
It's been really exciting
to see OpenClaw
grow into something
much bigger;
a global movement
and a community.
And I started the OpenClaw
Foundation, a real nonprofit,
so it stays open and neutral,
any model, any operating system.
Because we are entering a new
era of building these agents.
More capability for the
people who don't code
and more power for those who do.
And we get to do this.
We get to build it
together in the open.
So my task is simple:
Come build with us.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Scott Hanselman: Fantastic.
Thank you very much to Peter.
Thank you to Samantha.
Thank you to the Companion
App team for their hard work.
Thank you to the
OpenClaw community
for giving everyone here a
crustacean of their own.
And as we walk out,
I want to remind you
that that's the first time
you've ever seen OpenClaw
running on a Surface
Laptop Ultra. Goodbye.
[ Applause ]
Satya Nadella: All right,
thank you so much,
Samantha, Scott, and Peter.
It's so wonderful to see
OpenClaw come to Windows
and have all of that capability
in terms of the security
and that comfort to be able to
have these long-running agents
and unmetered intelligence
come together.
So now, let's move from the
Windows-side on the edge
to the cloud with Foundry.
And we are building Foundry into
this full application platform
for the agent era, right?
I mean, every era of the
platform shift when we moved
to the cloud, we had the
Cloud-native App stack,
and now we have the Agent-native
App stack in Foundry.
We are particularly excited
about the Foundry-hosted agent
as a runtime for
long-running agents.
Agents now have -- so,
if you're building
in Foundry-hosted agents, you
can have all the IQ layers.
You have the tools.
You have the durability and
the memory and the state.
You have your own sandbox.
In fact, it's a super-fast
sandbox that you can spin up.
You can generate the rubrics,
you can -- and the evals.
You can, in fact, have all
the safety and the guardrails
around your agentic system.
And, in fact, even one
of the coolest things
in Foundry is,
it's a continuously
improving loop even, right?
It's got that self-improvement
loop built in, right?
So you build an agent that's
continuously getting better.
And I'm really also excited
today to announce a partnership
with Fireworks AI,
bringing, in fact,
all of their open-weight
models to Foundry.
That means giving you, as
developers, more choices,
as well as their
great inference stack
to build the next generation
of these agentic applications
with all the enterprise
rails that Foundry has,
as well as the
governance Foundry has.
So, really excited about
that partnership.
[ Applause ]
And so, now that brings
us to the tools.
GitHub itself is at
the heart of all this.
You know, in fact,
Jensen spoke to this;
The GitHub is not just
about the code repo,
it's becoming the control
plane for all the agents.
And nearly everything
we measure on GitHub,
whether it's repo creation, PR
activity, API usage, actions,
all of them are growing faster
because of these
agentic workflows.
This new scale is
driven by humans
and agents
collaborating together.
And we are exposing our tooling
across every form factor.
In fact, we have seen tremendous
growth in CLI-driven --
you know, the approachability
of the CLI form factor.
It's always been great
to go to a terminal.
And now, though, when combined
with the power of the models
and natural language, you
know, CLI has become the thing
that everybody goes to.
But at the end of the day, when
you have hundreds of CLIs,
it becomes pretty complicated.
It doesn't scale, especially
the cognitive load that I have
when you have 100 CLI sessions
open is such that you kind
of need something new.
And so, that's what has led
us to build, you know,
we need like this tool,
essentially, that has the speed
and the flexibility of a CLI,
but has the capability of an IDE
and the ability to scale
to infinite number
of agent sessions.
And so, today we are taking
that next big step,
introducing our new
GitHub Copilot app.
[ Applause ]
And we realize that it's
not sufficient
because you still have a
backend to deal with, right?
Code is easy to generate,
but what about the backend?
So you need to contend
with identities,
storage, database schemas.
And that's why we are really
super excited about Rayfin.
Rayfin is an agent-first SDK
that connects your agents
to a backend-as-a-service
and we are bringing this
to everywhere you build.
That's why I'm, again,
super excited about Rayfin
and the partnership with Replit.
You can now build apps in
Replit while the -- yeah.
[ Applause ]
You can build the app
in Replit while the app
and data are deployed into the
enterprise-managed fabric tenant
thanks to the Rayfin SDK.
And so, this Rayfin SDK is
available now for anyone else
to be able to use with
their tools as a backend
and essentially have
this backend service.
And now to show you all
of the Foundry and Rayfin
and building agents and
the long-running agents,
let me invite up
on stage Cassidy.
Cassidy, take it away.
[ Cheering ]
[ Applause ]
Cassidy Williams:
Hello, everyone.
I'm so excited to be amongst
my fellow devs today.
This has been a long day.
Fix your shoulders,
sit back, all right.
I see a lot of you sitting up.
Great, great.
I know you're drinking from the
firehose of information today,
so I want you to go into the
next few minutes thinking,
"What can I try out on
my laptop later today?"
So, as Satya said, we're going
to show you Rayfin, but first,
I can't wait to show you
the new GitHub Copilot app.
This app is your home base for
development and operations
on your computer, and we think
you're going to love it.
So, let me show you around.
When you open up the
app from the start,
you see this home screen here
where you can kick off a
new agentic coding session.
But also, before I get
into the serious stuff,
you can drag Mona around,
and there's a game.
Look, it's so fun.
Okay, I'm not very good at it
so let's just get back to --
you can kick off a new
agentic coding session.
So, I started off one a
little bit earlier here,
and it gave me a review of a
bunch of release blockers.
Which one should I fix?
Call it out. . .
Eight? Three?
The "critical" ones?
You know what?
How about we just
do all of them?
Let's go.
This app will now kick off a separate
session for every single issue here.
I don't have to worry about
stashing or coding complex
or anything, because
the app takes care
of that, with git work trees.
Git-worktrees are isolated
environments for each session
that you run so your
agents can work in parallel
without stepping on each other.
But you still have to
merge them, right?
So, Copilot has your
back there too.
If I head over, not to this
one, but to this issue here,
I can run "Agent merge".
And when I enable "Agent merge",
Copilot will continuously
babysit this PR
through CI checks, code
review, and merge conflicts.
Okay, let me keep showing you
around while those
are still running.
Now, if I head over to "My work",
I can see a focused view of all
of my activity and just
projects loaded in the app,
issues and PRs, everything here.
And then under automations,
I have a bunch
of reusable sessions
and workflows
that can run locally
or on the cloud.
You see there's
"Issue Poetry" there?
That is real, and
that is load-bearing.
Okay. And now, under "Sessions",
like I briefly showed
earlier, these are sessions.
If I want to add
a new repository,
I can click that button
here, and it can pull
from a local repo or from
a GitHub repository.
And then if I were
to just add one,
I can add a session
in "pocketcal".
This is an open-source repo.
I can start a session anywhere,
and it just loads it.
I don't have to clone,
I don't have to pull,
it just works.
Now, when I look at a session
within this repository --
let me look at this
other one over here.
I get an integrated browser.
There's a terminal, I can
see the chat, it's all loading.
I can even toggle light
mode and dark mode in here.
And there's also this great
button, "Pick and Polish",
where if I click that, I can
pick and polish anything
in this app, and it
adds it to the chat.
And I can say, "Hey, I want you
to add reordering to this list",
and it'll just work,
all living in there.
I have access to all the most
popular models via my single
GitHub Copilot subscription,
including those from OpenAI,
Anthropic, and Google.
You can see all of them
in our model picker.
And having model
choice is great.
Not only can you pick the
right model for the task,
but for bigger features,
Copilot can request a
Rubber Duck review.
So, in this session
here, for example,
I was using GPT-5.5,
but if I scroll up, it
actually requested one
from Claude Opus 4.8.
All models have blind
spots, and the power
of the Copilot multimodel
approach means
that I can catch them earlier.
And this is all very cool.
But working with AI in 2026
should be more than just chat.
You just saw me scrolling that,
there's so many words here.
So, today I'm very excited
to show you the
concept of a "canvas".
I'm going to open
one right there.
The canvas is how an agent
can build a custom UI
to communicate with you.
What if your AI could see?
Everyone say, "Demo
Gods, bless us."
Okay, let's see if it works.
Here is a fun canvas where, if
I get the camera going -- okay,
the agent shows your PRs down
here, and I can toggle it
with a thumbs up
or a thumbs down.
Let's approve it. . .
Hey! It's so fun!
[ Applause ]
And they can go so much
deeper if you want.
This is just the beginning
of what you can do.
So, again, I kicked off a bunch
of different sessions earlier.
This is a signal box app.
It's 100% agent-built.
It's containerized with
a database backend.
Would you be able to deploy
this to your enterprise
with no questions asked?
Be honest.
No. Yes. Exactly, no.
But -- you can with Rayfin.
And that is very, very exciting.
Let me open up a new
terminal over here.
All I have to do
is type "rayfin up".
And then. . . Demo
Gods, bless us -- come on!
It will. . .
maybe deploy!
Blamo! It's happening!
Yes!
And all hosted on
Microsoft Fabric.
Okay, I know that's a lot.
I know that's a lot.
With Rayfin, your agents get a
complete enterprise backend
so you can deploy
with confidence
in the way that's best for you.
But this is the key
thing to remember:
This app is not just
another session manager --
-- yes, it is.
It manages a lot of sessions.
But session managers just
make it easy to create work.
But GitHub Copilot
helps you to finish it.
Thank you so much.
Happy Pride.
Back to you, Satya.
[ Cheering ]
[ Applause ]
Satya Nadella:
All right.
Now we're back to
IDEs that have UI.
That's sort of so cool.
You know, it kind of
comes a full circle.
Now let's talk about how
you can observe, govern,
and secure these agents.
Agent 365 is the
agent control plane.
Agent requires their own
identities, access controls,
even when they're working
on your behalf, right?
You just want that
work on behalf,
identity to be enforced,
so we extended Entra.
Agents need real-time defense,
so we extended Defender.
Agents require this always-on
data protections and compliance,
so we extended Purview.
And these agents can
be hosted anywhere.
They can be on AWS,
GCP, not just on Azure,
or built with any framework.
And today we're announcing
a number of updates,
including the GA
of Agent 365 SDK.
And we're expanding it to your
local agents running on Windows
and elsewhere and the "claws"
you just saw earlier.
And let us take a look at how
all of Agent 365 composes.
Over to you, Amanda.
[ Applause ]
AMANDA FOSTER: Everyone
is building agents.
But that's not the
hard part anymore.
The hard part is integrating
them into your business
and governing them at-scale.
Today, I'll show you how
Foundry makes this easy.
Let's start locally.
I've already built
a LangGraph agent.
And now, I'll show you
the value Foundry adds.
First, tools.
Agents need tools
to get work done.
And with Foundry Toolbox,
I just add my tools once
and any agent can consume them
through a single MCP endpoint.
And because tools
live centrally,
that means governance
does as well.
I've applied a guardrail,
which blocks PII from leaking
into tool calls and
tool responses.
And all I have to do
is apply this once,
and all my agents are protected.
Now, let's make this
agent enterprise-ready.
To deploy this agent to Foundry
all I have to do is add
this one block of code;
and then I push my changes,
and GitHub Actions
takes it from there.
Once deployed, I can
actually use this agent
in the same Foundry extension
I showed you earlier,
and let's now test it out.
I'm asking it to track
a few open items
from a stand-up I
had earlier today.
And what's actually happening
right now is Foundry is spinning
up a dedicated micro VM
just for this session.
And the session even gets its
own persistent file system.
What you're going to see in a
minute here, is if I go to the
"Files" tab to track
the open items,
the agent's actually
writing to a file.
Pretty cool, right?
Plus, Foundry now has
server-side traces
and built-in evals to show
me exactly what happened
on every run.
But how do I know if my
agent's doing a good job?
That's what Foundry's brand new
rubric evaluators are for.
It's super simple.
With just one AZD command,
Foundry reads my agent
and then generates the
evaluation criteria for me.
In other words, it creates
a rubric personalized just
to this agent.
Now let's check out this
rubric in Foundry Portal.
Look at these dimensions.
Governance outcome correctness,
prescribed source usage.
I didn't write any of these.
Foundry generated them
from production traces.
And with this rubric, I can
score my agent and run evals.
But we can do so
much more than that.
That's where Foundry's brand-new
agent optimizer takes over.
Here's how it works.
It tunes four things:
the model, instructions, tool
descriptions, and skills.
And then it generates,
improves candidates,
and scores each one using the
rubric I just showed you.
Here, I can view the candidates.
I can see the strategy used.
I can see their scores.
And I can actually view
exactly what changed.
This candidate, for
example, improved its score
by updating the model
and the system prompt.
Foundry then makes it super easy
to deploy the best candidate
as a brand-new agent version.
But this is not a
one-time thing.
Every run feeds the next eval,
and every eval tells the
optimizer where to improve next.
So, your agents now get better
the more they're used.
But now, let's put
this agent to work.
I've published my agent to
Teams and M365 Copilot.
And right now, I'm going
to ask it to just catch me
up on what I've missed
because I've been offline all
morning but my agent hasn't.
While it works on that, though,
let me explain what makes
this agent different.
This is an autopilot agent
which means it has
its own identity
and productivity license.
So, it can work across
M365 on its own behalf.
Earlier, you saw me using
this agent by myself,
but shipping a feature in a new
release takes a whole team.
And that's why this agent
lives in our Teams group Chat.
Now let's check out how it did.
It summarized all
updates and called
out the key features I
need to be tracking.
But to put an agent like
this, actually to work,
in your enterprise, governance
needs to come first.
And that's why every autopilot
agent requires admin approval.
Here, admins can review
all critical details,
and they can even choose
who has the ability
to talk to the agent.
But it doesn't end there.
Even after approval, admins can
continue to monitor the agent
and block it at any time.
But governance cannot
apply to just one agent.
Every agent in your organization
needs to be managed
with the same rigor as
users, apps, and devices.
And that's exactly what
Microsoft Agent 365 provides.
So, let's zoom out.
Today we saw Foundry accelerate
development, take your agent
from local to enterprise-ready,
and put it to work in M365.
Foundry makes it simple.
You build the agent,
we handle the rest.
Now back to you, Satya.
[ Applause ]
Satya Nadella:
Thank you, Amanda.
[ Applause ]
You know, what you just saw was
how we're building security
for AI.
But there is also one other
critical aspect, especially,
you know, the news today
is all about, you know,
how do you defend yourself using
AI against attacks that may,
in fact, be using AI, right?
So, last month we announced our
multi-model agentic security
system, MDASH.
That's essentially an agent
harness for security,
essentially, that we built.
We're bringing together 100
agents across theFrontier
and custom models to really find
these exploitable bugs better
than any single model does.
In fact, when we debuted this
harness, it was on the top
of CyberGym benchmark.
So, I want you to take a look
at what you can do with MDASH
to really defend
against AI attacks
and defend the entire
digital estate.
Over to you, Sarah.
[ Applause ]
Sarah Young:
Thanks, Satya.
Now, we all know that security
scans can take a while,
so I'm not going to do one live.
So, let me show you the results
of an MDASH scan I already
ran on my code base.
Now, the system runs
as a standalone CLI,
but today I'm using it
in my GitHub Copilot app
on my local dev machine.
The scan is broken down
by vulnerability domains
and severity, and it's also,
additional to finding
traditional issues
like coding errors and
hard-coded secrets,
it's also identifying
AI-specific vulnerabilities
in the code base.
Now, what happened
under the hood is
that over 100 specialized
agents are working together
to discover, debate,
and prove exploitable
vulnerabilities end-to-end.
And when the scan finishes,
it generates both a SARIF log
and an HTML report that I
can give to my management.
Now, the "defender details"
command allows me to dig
into these vulnerabilities,
and I can see what
the vulnerability is,
where it is in my code, and the
severity to help me prioritize.
And from here, of course,
we're going to fix it.
Now, using the
"defender fix" command,
the system will remediate
suggested fixes directly
in my local dev environment.
And when that's done, I
can check out the "diff".
So, I have full transparency
about what the harness has done,
and I still have a
human-in-the-loop check.
But, of course,
everything I've shown you
so far has run locally, but I
can also create a PR to plug
into my existing workflows
and push up to my repo.
And I can take the SARIF
output from the scan,
and I can upload it to tools
like GitHub Advanced Security
and manage everything
alongside my other application
security findings.
Now, I've shown you MDASH
working on my code,
but let me show you a
vulnerability our security
research teams
identified using MDASH
that you can go and
look up yourself.
So, the TLDR, because this is
a lot to read, of this bug is
that WASM time reads an
out-of-date map of an object,
runs off the end, and
then it crashes the host.
So, this is exactly
the kind of bug
that the harness was built for,
because the flow is spread
across three different
parts of the code base.
So, no single file looks
wrong on its own.
They look absolutely fine,
and we can even see here,
which is probably my
favorite part of this bug,
a very confident statement
from the developers claiming
everything is fine.
Now, this is exactly
the sort of reassurance
that fools normal scanners
and single AI models.
But MDASH wasn't fooled.
One team of agents spotted
the suspicious gap,
another team argued it apart,
and a third team built
a working example
that actually
triggered the crash.
And it did all of this in
an open-source code base.
And this is the kind
of joined-up reasoning
that previously required
significant manual security
research effort.
This is MDASH helping
developers create secure code
from the start, coming
soon to your CLI
and the Microsoft
Defender portal.
Back to you, Satya.
[ Applause ]
Satya Nadella:
Thank you, Sarah.
So, that was the stack.
Before, though, we
move to unpacking more
of the opportunity, I want
to do something different.
I want to introduce two people
whose LinkedIn profiles were
both super impressive
and slightly perplexing.
Under current role, it says
they're general partners
at Mantis VC.
Under previous role,
it says they sold
out Madison Square Garden.
Please help me welcome Alex and
Drew from the Chainsmokers.
Alex, Drew.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Satya Nadella: It's so wonderful
to see you, Alex.
Thank you so much.
You know, one of the things when
my team came to me and said,
"Hey, we're going to have
Chainsmokers at Build."
I thought maybe that's what
we're calling our new GitHub
Copilot app.
But, you know, it's so, I
thought maybe they're your fans.
But tell me about how
you got into this.
I mean, you've been
at it, now, for what --
12-plus years
as venture capitalists or
angel investors first,
and you've had your firm
now for seven-plus years.
And you even picked what I would
have not thought is the natural
place, which is B2B SaaS
even as the first place.
Just give us a little bit
about the back story on this.
DREW TAGGART:
Sure. Well --
-- Hey, I'm sure you guys are
wondering what timeline you're
on where the Chainsmokers
are at Microsoft Build.
But hey, how are you?
We've been in the Chainsmokers
for 14 years, and, you know,
when our music started to take
off in the mid-2000 teens,
we got to play a few
events like this.
And we met a lot of the founders
from the consumer mobile
cloud era of startups,
and they taught us a lot and
gave us a front-row seat
into what early-stage
investing was like.
We fell in love with it.
We found a lot of --
we had a lot in common
with these founders, and the way
that they built their business
was the same way that we thought
about starting the Chainsmokers
and, you know, kind of breaking
through the noise there.
And, you know, we
got to participate
in a few of their deals.
We were very lucky, and we
decided to institutionalize
in 2020 and start our own fund.
Satya Nadella: That's so cool.
And when you sort of hear
about all this AI stuff
and what's happening, obviously
there's a lot even going on.
Even in your portfolio, we
were talking backstage,
things are changing.
How do you sort of see the
opportunity going forward?
ALEX PALL: I mean, there's
so many vectors you could
talk about this on.
Of course, there's the
creative output side which --
Satya Nadella: Yeah.
ALEX PALL: -- you know,
we've been experimenting
with in music, but
always important
to have your authenticity
when it comes to creativity.
But on the investment
side, I think we're moving
from producing outputs
to producing actions,
which I think presents, like,
a very interesting opportunity
to kind of reimagine the entire
architecture of the way software
and enterprise has been built.
So, instead of humans, you
know, producing outputs,
it's machines producing
outputs and rethinking what
that entire space looks
like in that context.
Satya Nadella: Yeah, no,
it's fantastic to see that.
And maybe just to close
out, any sort of,
as artists who have had,
you know, great success,
when you look at a founder,
what sort of is the advice you
give them when you're creating,
you know, you're
bringing something new?
And it's a creative process.
So, what are you looking
for in founders?
What is it that you're
giving them as advice?
DREW TAGGART: Totally.
I mean, there really
are so many parallels.
Maybe it seems like that.
Maybe it doesn't.
But, I mean, it's really
difficult as artists
to really find, I guess,
what your sound is,
what's authentically you, what
you can continue to do over
and over because with
this much competition,
you have to be moving
authentically.
You have to be connected to the
product that you're creating
and because you're going to have
to iterate and keep it going
and have consistency for a long
period of time to kind of lock
into your fan base and make
something that's special
and unique.
And, you know, we try
to advise our founders
to do the same thing.
Satya Nadella: Fantastic.
Thank you both for joining us.
Are you game for playing
for us this evening
for our closest friends here?
ALEX PALL: We'll be there.
Satya Nadella: Six
o'clock, six this evening.
Thank you so much.
DREW TAGGART: Thank you.
ALEX PALL:
Thank you so much.
Satya Nadella: Thank you,
thank you.
[ Applause ]
Satya Nadella: So, we'll be
right here at 6 p.m. tonight
and really looking
forward to it.
So, that effectively,
sort of, talks a little bit
about the developer stack.
So, now let's talk about
what is the opportunity
for every company, right?
At the end of the day,
we are institution
and organizational
builders. How --
-- if whether it's an
AI-native company,
whether it's a SaaS company,
whether it's an enterprise,
the first thing we want
to do is make sure
that, as you build things
like plugins or agents
or your AI apps, we
want to make sure
that they're discovered
throughout the
Microsoft ecosystem.
That's job number one for us.
That's why we're doing the
things we're doing in Windows
or the Microsoft 365 Copilot
or in Teams or in GitHub.
We want to structure them
such that your applications,
your agents, your
plugins are discovered.
Customers are also building
lots of line-of-business
applications,
line-of-business agents,
then using Copilot Studio.
And we want to make that all
discoverable again as part
of the Copilot experience.
And Teams, in some sense,
has become this destination
for multiplayer,
human-to-agent interaction.
We want you to be
able to find agents,
interact with agents,
right in Teams.
And we are supercharging
all of this.
Copilot continues to
evolve very quickly.
It started first with Chat,
with some of the best models,
with great access to Work IQ.
We didn't have the name Work
IQ, but now that's kind
of where it got started.
Then came Cowork, a
new way of working
and generating these
stunning artifacts
and solve these multi-step
problems, right?
So, you assign multi-step
tasks to Cowork.
You saw GitHub.
GitHub has continued
to evolve as well.
And now, as of --
you know,
come summer, you
will be bringing coding
to all knowledge work within
one Copilot super app, right?
That's going to be really
exciting to see, yeah?
[ Applause ]
So, you'll have Chat, Cowork,
and Code all in Copilot.
But today, we're introducing
something completely new.
Autopilots.
We can think of autopilots
as enterprise-grade "claws".
These are autonomous,
long-running agents
with full enterprise compliance
that run in your tenant.
Autopilots can have
a name, personality,
custom connectors,
context, and memory.
And they're a totally
new way to reduce toil
and get you back
to what you love.
To kick things off, the first
autopilot we are introducing
is Scout.
Let's take a look.
[ Music ]
Satya Nadella:
All right.
[ Applause ]
As you can see, Scout
works where you work,
joining group chats and Teams,
handling threads in Outlook.
Starting today, for those of you
who are on CopilotFrontier,
you can try out Scout.
And in the coming months,
we will build this
out to a complete digital team
of autopilots right
inside of Copilot.
So, you can go to
the Copilot app.
Scout is the one that
comes by default.
But you can build more
of these autopilots.
And so, that's the
future of what we think
of as the Copilot
ecosystem itself.
And so far, we have talked
a lot about what you can do
to build your own agents and
how these agents are discovered
in things like Copilot
and Teams and Windows.
But when you think about
what makes any organization,
any enterprise, any
company unique,
it is its tacit knowledge that
it's continuously compounding
through its operations.
So, the key consideration at
some level in an AI age is
to ask the question, what's
the future of the firm?
How do you continue to
preserve and compound
that tacit knowledge
in the age of AI
where models can learn
anything from the data
and the trajectories they see?
To do that, we believe
that every organization,
whether it's an AI-native
company, a SaaS company,
or any enterprise, will need
to build their own
hill climbing machine.
It's a system that
continuously improves
against your objectives,
your private evals,
compounding your advantage
over time, not someone else's.
To deliver on this, we're
taking the next step
with Frontier Tuning.
We have been working with
many customers already
to help really build their own
learning loop, the environment,
the context, the
tools, the rubrics,
and even train their own models.
And today, we are really
thrilled and excited
about supercharging that
Frontier Tuning capability
with the innovation
that's coming
out of our
superintelligence lab.
To tell you all about this, let
me hand it over to Mustafa.
Mustafa.
[ Applause ]
Mustafa Suleyman:
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Good morning, everybody.
You know, we really are living
in the most remarkable times.
Since I started working in
AI, the compute that we use
to train Frontier models has
increased by one trillion fold.
That's 12 orders of magnitude of
computation in just 15 years.
It's now clear that a
consistent, exponential increase
in computation leads
to predictable advances
in AI capabilities.
And in the next few years, we're
going to see three more orders
of magnitude of compute applied
to train Frontier models.
Intelligence is now a
function of compute.
Log linear hill climbing
has become the norm.
The scaling laws are
clearly holding,
and it is a remarkable
time in our industry.
And so, in this context,
we at MAI are building
towards what we call humanist
superintelligence,
state-of-the-art AI capabilities
that are explicitly
designed to serve people
and organizations and
not replace them.
Because the type of AI that
we create really does matter.
We need an AI that
places humanity first,
but always prioritizes human
well-being and human progress.
This is the core philosophy
and motivation behind our
superintelligence efforts
at Microsoft, and it shapes
everything that we do.
And as a platform company,
our job and our commitment is
to keep you developers building
at the absolute Frontier.
So, today we are very
excited to announce a family
of seven new models
across Image, Voice,
Transcription, and Coding.
[ Applause ]
These are all built with
real attention to detail
and a commitment to making very
practical and efficient tools
that are tuned to just how
you work in the real world.
So, first up, MAI Image-2.5
and its Flash variant,
two superstrong models
that deliver a step change
in quality, now at number
two on the leaderboard,
surpassing the score of Nano
Banana 2 on image editing.
[ Applause ]
They give you precise editing
with incredible control
and consistency, Flash is here
for super-efficient production
workloads, while 2.5 gives you
that maximum fidelity and
professional-grade performance.
They're live in PowerPoint
today, they're rolling
out to OneDrive, and right now
you can access them on Foundry
at a market-leading
quality per dollar.
Next up, we've got
MAI Transcribe-1.5.
This is the best transcription
model in the world.
State-of-the-art accuracy across
43 languages, beating out Gemini
and OpenAI's flagship
transcription models.
We've optimized it
for real-world use
so that you can produce
highly accurate transcripts
for any bespoke use
case five times faster
than all rival models.
It's now being integrated inside
of GitHub, Teams, Copilot,
Dynamics 365, Contact Center,
and it's now also available
in Foundry, where
I'm very excited
to say it is the
fastest, most efficient,
and most cost-effective
transcription model of any
of the hyperscalers out there.
[ Applause ]
So, paired with that,
we've got MAI Voice-2.
This is our latest
speech generation model.
It has beautiful prosody,
natural-sounding delivery,
fine-grained emotional
control, and it's available
in 15 languages, with
many more coming soon.
We're also announcing
Voice 2-Flash,
and that provides the
very best value and speed
for ultra-latency-sensitive
voice agents, which, of course,
is the big thing in 2026.
Next up, our text foundation
model, MAI Thinking-1.
This is our first
reasoning model,
and it's exceptionally strong
in our target use cases
of reasoning and SWE tasks.
It's a 35 billion
active parameter MOE
with a 256k context window.
That means that it competes in
the medium-sized weight class,
where it's certainly
punching above its weight.
And independent human
raters on Surge prefer it
in overall quality side-by-sides
versus Sonnet 4.6.
[ Applause ]
It's achieved 97% on AIME 2025,
which is obviously
the key measure
of its general-purpose
reasoning abilities.
But most importantly of
all, it's now at 53%
on SWE Bench Pro, which places
it right alongside Opus 4.6,
at least on the toughest coding
benchmark that's out there.
So, we're very happy with that.
[ Applause ]
Now, there's plenty more
for us to do as we get this
into production, and hill
climb against real-world tasks
and real-world traffic.
But what is actually most
remarkable about this model,
we think, is that it is climbed
entirely from the bottom.
And that means that it
hasn't targeted any
of the benchmarks
specifically, and it's done
so with absolutely
zero distillation.
And to us, this is
critical, because it means
that the model is created with
an enterprise-grade, clean,
and commercially licensed
data lineage that means
that you can put
it into production
in a very trustworthy way
with complete confidence.
Now, finally, I'm
incredibly excited
to announce MAI Code-1-Flash.
This is our new
inference-efficient coding
model, which has been especially
tuned for VS Code and,
of course, GitHub Copilot CLI.
It achieves 51%
on SWE Bench Pro,
despite having just 5
billion parameters.
And so, it's much closer to
Haiku in terms of size,
but cheaper in cost, delivering
really strong coding performance
at great inference efficiency.
And it's rolling out
today inside of VS Code.
[ Applause ]
Now, alongside distribution
on Foundry and optimization
for our 1P products,
we're also very excited
to make our models
available on Open Router,
as well as Fireworks
and BaseTen.
So, this means that, for the
first time, you're going
to be able to tune the
weights directly yourself
in an ecosystem of your choice.
Now, across this entire family,
safety and security have been
built in from the start.
Our voice models come
with protections
against unauthorized cloning.
Everything is watermarked
from scratch.
We've reduced our over-refusals,
improved representation,
including for people
with disabilities.
We're also publishing a very
detailed technical report today
to give you a full and
transparent understanding
of how we put all
of this together.
Now, one of the things I'm
particularly excited about is
that we have been carefully
co-designing our models
with our own silicon.
So, that means that we've
optimized MAI-Thinking-1
on our very own Maia 200 chip
and benchmarked it head-to-head
against the GB200.
And so, on top of the 30%
performance improvement
that Satya talked about earlier,
we're now seeing a further
1.4x performance per watt gain
when we run our MAI models
on the Maia 200 end-to-end.
And that's huge.
Because, as everybody knows, at
this scale, every watt counts.
And silicon and model co-design
is a really key advantage
that we think is going to help
keep everybody here right
on the Frontier with
the most efficient
and most powerful thinking
and coding agents out there.
We're also super excited
that these faster
and more efficient MAI
models are coming to the N1X
that Satya mentioned
a few moments ago.
And we think that's
going to be able
to deliver the very best
performance on Windows
in a few months' time.
Now, to us, this is what owning
the full stack end-to-end
looks like.
It's the foundation of
Microsoft Frontier Tuning.
It lets you customize the MAI
models using our full stack
hill-climbing machine
right where you want it.
And it means that
the disciplined
and very relentless
engineering that has gone
into building our models is
now available to all of you
on a platform that you can
trust, working on your behalf,
to create custom agents
that you will control.
So, the really big thing,
of course, that's happened
in the last year is these RLEs,
reinforcement learning
environments,
these unique training
gyms for your AIs.
They create company
and task-specific
agents adapted only
to you, built on MAI models.
So, for example,
within Microsoft,
we use our RLEs combined
with our MAI models
to climb towards the best
agentic use cases on Excel.
Our MAI-tuned model is now on
par with GPT-5.4 on public
and private benchmarks,
whilst at the same time being 10
times more efficient on cost.
Thank you.
You know, and many other
early adopters are seeing
similar results.
When we've tuned our models on
McKinsey's tasks, MAI delivered
the highest win rate, even
outperforming GPT-5.5,
and, again, delivering 10x
greater efficiency on cost.
So, to us, this is the advantage
of very carefully
calibrated Frontier Tuning.
And importantly, unlike with
some of the other companies,
with MAI, you don't rent
intelligence from a shared model
that learns from everybody.
Only you keep the benefits of
your hard-earned workflows,
know-how, knowledge, and
your own institutional data.
Only you get to control
the resulting model.
And so, with us, the RLEs and
the models that you build inside
of them, they become your moat.
And I really think
this is distinct.
It marks a new era in AI
that we're all very,
very excited about.
Okay, so now, just one
final announcement
that I'm very excited about.
We are taking customization
and co-creation of our models
to the highest level
possible on what I think of as,
perhaps, the most important
application of AI:
Healthcare.
So today, we're very proud to be
announcing that we're partnering
with Mayo Clinic to jointly
develop a new Frontier model
for health and then deploy
it around the world
in their hospitals and beyond.
So, this morning, please
help me in welcoming
to the stage a physician,
ground-breaking researcher,
president and CEO of the Mayo
Clinic, Dr. Gianrico Farrugia.
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
Mustafa Suleyman:
Thank you so much
for being here, Gianrico.
Now, of course, everyone
will recognize Mayo
as, perhaps, the leading
hospital in the world
with an incredible track record
of research and innovation
and clinical practice.
Tell us a little bit more
about what you hope to get
out of our collaboration.
Gianrico Farrugia:
Well, first of all,
thanks for having me here.
Thanks to Satya as well.
Mayo Clinic is known
for being able to live
up to our primary value.
The needs of the
patient come first.
We deliver outstanding
healthcare.
We're ranked the number one
healthcare organization
in the world.
Yet we know most people
in the world will not have
access to Mayo Clinic.
So, seven years ago, we
decided to create a platform,
the Mayo Clinic platform,
moving all of healthcare
from a pipeline to a platform.
And with our partners,
that platform now is
in four continents and reaches
about 100 million people.
It has created the
largest, to our knowledge,
deepest longitudinal healthcare
data set in the world,
multimodal, including genomics.
So, here together, now
we have the opportunity
to do what we do best together,
which is create a Frontier
model for healthcare.
What it means if
you're a patient,
if you're somebody interested in
healthcare, you can get clinical
and logistical answers
to your healthcare.
But if you're a healthcare
provider, if you're a physician,
it can give you insight,
it can act as your
real-time team member
that can tell you what is
likely to happen next.
But it can also prevent
harm and, therefore,
increase patient safety and
giving valuable insights
that make the team better at
giving you what you need most,
which is better healthcare.
Mustafa Suleyman: Yeah, and I
think that one of the things
that we're most excited about is
that the models are
already pretty incredible
at textbook knowledge.
They've read all the
journals and all the papers.
But what they're really lacking
is the kind of clinical practice
and clinical expertise of
your team and your clinicians
that you've developed over
the last many decades.
So, how do you think we
might go about using
that clinical practice to
improve the performance
of the model in production?
Gianrico Farrugia:
So, the exciting part here is
we each do what we do best
and we can tackle something
that has eluded healthcare
for a long time: trusted,
scalable solutions.
And to do that, you need
to have the right data,
you certainly need to have the
right people, but you also need
to have a very
patient-focused lens.
And between the two of us, we
now have all this together
so that we can build
this Frontier model
and then offer safe, secure,
trustworthy, and, of course,
effective healthcare
solutions for all.
Mustafa Suleyman: Well, our
number one objective, of course,
is to put the patient first,
deliver the highest quality
we can in a trusted way,
and then, hopefully, share
that with the world over.
So, we're very excited
for this partnership,
can't wait to share more
with everyone in the future.
Gianrico Farrugia: Us too.
Thank you.
Mustafa Suleyman: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Mustafa Suleyman:
So, today marks some
very, very exciting
steps that we're taking
on our journey to create
humanist superintelligence
at Microsoft.
We now have an incredible roster
of seven new world-class models
to keep everybody working
at the absolute Frontier.
And we're really looking
forward to everybody being able
to co-create your own
unique agents adapted
to you that you'll control.
I really feel like this is a
new era in AI; an era of AI
that you control on your terms.
So, let's build it together.
Thank you very much, everyone.
[ Applause ]
And now over to Tanaya to show
us how Frontier Tuning works
in practice.
[ Applause ]
Tanaya Yadav: Thanks, Mustafa.
With Frontier Tuning, we're
making it possible for you
to create your own enterprise
AI with the models
and the harness tuned on your
data and your workflows.
Let me show you how
you can build your own
hill-climbing machine.
MAI Thinking-1 is now
available in private preview
in the Foundry model catalog.
You can go ahead and deploy the
model as is, or if you want
to go on your own hill-climbing
journey, you can start
by clicking the
"Fine Tune" button.
Now, I'm in the fine tuning UI.
The first thing I'll
do is add my data set.
Next, I'm going to add a
grader, and that's it.
I go ahead and submit the job.
A couple of hours in, I see
how the model is learning.
It generates roll-outs,
it scores them,
and we start to hill-climb.
Now, if you want full control
over your RL training loop,
let me give you a sneak peek
into our low-level training API.
You can see here I have
the MAI thinking model.
I can also configure my
roll-out strategy as well
as my hyper-parameters to define
exactly how I want my training
algorithm to work.
In fact, I can also
incorporate my own RL gym here
by defining the tools that
this model interacts with.
All right, you just
saw all the code.
But as an M365 customer, you're
never starting from scratch.
Let's hop on to Copilot.
As a part of Frontier Tuning,
we're introducing a new way
to build RL environments based
on your data and your workflows.
One of our customers,
Land O'Lakes,
one amongst the largest
agri-businesses
in the United States, is in
fact, using this to perfect
that butter on your
morning toast.
Let me walk you through
their environment.
Now, on a high level,
the environment consists
of skills, knowledge, and tools.
But in the backend, we create
an entire RL gym for your agents
to continuously learn
the way that you work.
Now, let's look at the "Butter
Report Generation" skill here.
These tasks are very complex.
They require many manual steps
and a high degree of precision.
Now, in these tasks, even 80%
accuracy isn't good enough.
To hill-climb to
higher accuracy,
we're extending the industry
definition of skills
to include rubrics on
what "good" looks like.
But this is just one task.
How do I scale
this to codify all
of these tasks in an enterprise?
You spend a lot of time in
M365, in Teams, Outlook, Word,
Excel, and PowerPoint.
We use those signals to
suggest skills in rubrics
that truly define the
way that you work.
Next, you can add your
organizational knowledge
for grounding, like from
OneDrive and SharePoint.
Now, the environment comes
built-in with Microsoft Tools,
and you can add
custom tools to it.
Because these tools tap
into real workflows,
we virtualize them to simulate
execution so the model can learn
without actually impacting the
live state of your business.
And now, my most favorite
part, the science.
By generalizing all of these
learnings into the "main" model,
as well as in the embedding
model, we're able to hill-climb
for tasks that require
high accuracy.
And not only this, we are
able to hill-climb to more
than 90% accuracy for Land
O'Lakes tasks using the
MAI model.
In fact, we estimate this
model to be 10x more efficient
than the baseline models.
Now, with this
environment set up,
let's go back to
"Butter" reporting.
Let's run this task, this time
using this tuned environment
as an inferencing harness.
Now, usually this task takes
a couple of minutes to run.
In the meantime, I will
show you a cached response.
Now, as you can see here,
the agent has leveraged
"Test-Time Tree Search"
with multiple models,
including a fine-tuned model.
And what you see
here is a summary
that doesn't feel generic.
It feels undoubtedly
Land O'Lakes.
And that's not it.
The task holds itself
to high standards,
and it continuously retrospects
and evaluates itself.
This way, with Frontier Tuning,
your agent continuously improves
with your compliant RL
environment on your data
and coding the way you work.
Now, that is what I
call Frontier Tuning
as smooth as butter.
We cannot wait to see the
environments you build.
Back to you, Satya.
Satya Nadella:
All right.
[ Applause ]
Satya Nadella:
Thank you so much,
Tanaya, Mustafa, Gianrico.
Thank you for the
partnership here.
You know, what you just saw is
a pretty significant shift.
We believe that times come for
every company to just move
from consuming a Frontier
model to fully participating
at the Frontier and the
Frontier ecosystem.
That's the transition.
You can have your own
private evals and outcomes,
your private RLEs and traces,
your enterprise knowledge,
create this scaffolding
for models to hill-climb.
That's what will allow you to
create that differentiated IP
that you own, you control.
But the second salient point is
that there is a new operating
point at the Frontier
where you can use a very
efficient reasoning model
and a coding model and achieve
Frontier-level performance
because you've done the
hard work of creating
that environment, that RLE,
that hill-climbing machine
in which these models with
your traces can hill climb
to the Frontier.
So, we think that
the combination
of these two is a pretty big
game-changer in how people think
about what does it mean to
operate at the Frontier?
What does Frontier
tokens look like?
How are you in control?
What's the future of a firm?
These are the big questions
and really an ecosystem
that gets built around as
opposed to a few models
that just are hungry
for all data.
To close out, though, I want to
talk about that Frontiers beyond
that push this ecosystem
of ours and really say,
"What's the next big thing?"
Bending the curve -- you know,
when Mustafa talked about this
with Gianrico when
it comes to health --
but building, you know,
that scientific discovery loop
can have, perhaps, the biggest
societal impact, right?
Science today still is
a little too linear.
You create a hypothesis --
you form a hypothesis,
you run an experiment,
you wait for lab results,
which is out of band, and
then you begin again.
But what if the scientific
method itself could become more
continuous, more parallel,
more programmable?
That's what we're doing with
Microsoft Discovery, right?
Discovery brings together
the models, the HPC compute,
the knowledge graphs of all
the scientific knowledge,
the automated lab and simulation
into one agentic discovery loop.
And so, today I'm
really thrilled
to GA Microsoft Discovery,
and to show you all of this
in action; let me invite
up David on stage.
David, take it away.
[ Applause ]
David Carmona:
Hello!
[ Applause ]
I work in the Microsoft
Discovery and Quantum team.
Today, to recycle a PET
plastic like this bottle,
you have to shred
it and melt it.
The result is degraded.
You cannot use it to
make this bottle again.
It's downcycling.
Cambridge Consultants,
part of Capgemini,
is using Microsoft Discovery
to advance that research.
Let me show it to you. . .
This is the Microsoft
Discovery app.
It is based on VS Code because
agentic discovery has many
parallels with agentic
software engineering.
Today, I want to do these
three things as a scientist.
First, I want to write
a scientific paper
about this topic.
I'll explore an existing
line of research.
Instead of melting the
plastic, I can use proteins
to the composite so you can
recycle it again and again.
Second, I want to perform
the actual discovery
to find new proteins.
And third, I want to
create a lab protocol
to test the results
in a real lab.
If you are a developer,
these three steps should
be very familiar to you.
They look a lot like
planning, coding and testing,
and deploying to production,
but for science.
Let's launch it.
This will kick off
the discovery engine.
You can think of this as a team
of specialized agents
always running
in the background following
the scientific method.
You can see those agents
here and you can add more.
Microsoft Discovery includes a
community of agents, models,
and tools across many domains.
You can use open-source,
third-parties, or create your own.
Okay, so, this is still running
and it will be running
for a while, even hours or days,
because the discovery engine,
like science, is not sequential.
It is exploring hypotheses
and performing long-running
simulations dynamically.
So, let me open one that
is already completed.
You can see the files
that it created here.
This one is the research
paper that I was asking for.
To create it, Discovery is using
a knowledge graph internally,
bringing together public
scientific literature
and internal knowledge.
This is a critical asset because
it provides complete visibility
of the reasoning so scientists
can be in full control.
We can go now to step two,
the discovery itself.
Let me open the
output for that one.
So, how do you come up with new
proteins to decompose plastic?
This is the approach
that Discovery took.
First, you need an AI model
to predict how good a
protein is for that.
Then, you need a way to
generate new proteins.
And finally, you need
to identify the most
promising ones.
So, let's start with the model.
Microsoft Discovery
trained multiple models
and picked the best.
And there's no out-of-the-box
agent for that.
But that's okay.
If Microsoft Discovery does
not find an agent for a task,
it will create one on the
fly, which is pretty cool.
So, here's all the
files that it created.
This one here is the
YAML for the agent.
And this one, for example,
is the Python code
to train the models.
Now, we need to generate
candidates for new proteins.
And that task requires
a lot of compute.
Discovery is integrated with
HPC, so agents can use it
for complex simulations.
You can see the process here.
It started with a seed protein
and then it created variations
by replacing small segments.
You can see those
segments there.
Then it applied the
model from before
to see the variation helps or
not, learning in that process.
This is done millions of
times in multiple jobs
in parallel exploring a
huge tree of proteins.
The result is 80 proteins that
are ready to be sent to the lab
for testing, which
we said it was
like deploying software, right?
The problem, though, is
that creating a protein is a
little bit more complicated.
The most common way is
inserting DNA into bacteria
so the bacteria create
the protein for me.
So, Discovery created another
file, this one here.
This file contains
all the DNA sequences
to create each protein.
I can send this now to a lab,
create the proteins
and test them.
Or, I can go one step further.
If I have an automated lab,
I can integrate it
directly with the agents.
Let's do it.
So, let me go
back to the session
and let's just
submit job to lab.
Go.
This will use a custom agent
that is sending instructions
for the lab equipment.
And this is very real.
Cambridge Consultants does
have an automated lab.
And I have it right here.
So, this is the application
control in the lab.
It has a Copilot interface so
the scientists can interact
with the lab to design
experiments, which is,
it feels like being Iron
Man but for chemistry.
In this case, Discovery
is admitting the job.
You can see it already here.
But remember, you need
to grow the bacteria
so this will take some time.
So, let me open a previous run.
And there you go.
These are all the steps
that the agents are doing.
Most of them
completely automated
with human supervision.
How cool is that?
[ Applause ]
This is bringing together
the physical world
and the digital agents in
a unified discovery loop.
And this was just one example of
what Microsoft Discovery can do.
Customers across industries
are using it today
to embrace a new era of
scientific discovery.
Thank you.
Back to you, Satya.
[ Applause ]
Satya Nadella: Thank
you so much, David.
Talking about scientific
discovery, we're also continuing
to make rapid progress
on our long-term goal
of building a scalable
quantum computer.
We announced last
year our first QPU.
We created a new state of matter
that was only theorized
100 years ago
and we proved it
out that it exists.
Our vision was to take a very
radically different approach
to addressing the
fundamental barriers
to building a scalable
quantum machine, which is all
about reliability,
speed, as well as size.
Since then, we have
continued to make progress
across the full quantum
stack with both our academic
and industry partners.
In fact, in QuNorth, we will
have a quantum computer powered
by atom computers,
natural atom computers,
with our stack in there.
We are also working
with Algorithmic
and Columbia and ETH Zurich.
And we ourselves, in fact, use
this discovery agentic loop
to accelerate the work in
quantum, compressing years
of research into this last year.
And today, I'm really thrilled
to announce Majorana 2.
And so, this is Majorana 2.
Majorana 2 implements the
next-generation material stack
that we use discovery
to discover
and build and help fabricate.
The resulting qubits are
exceptionally reliable
and capable of maintaining
their state much longer.
While other common approaches
deliver a lifetime
of just microseconds
or even milliseconds,
Majorana 2 provides qubit mean
lifetime of 20 seconds or up
to even a minute, essentially
a thousand times higher
than what we were able to
achieve with Majorana 1.
[ Applause ]
And the operations,
and this is so key,
operations in Majorana
2 are one microsecond,
enabling pretty complex, quantum
computation in that lifetime.
And all of this in the same
qubit form factor of Majorana 1
in one one-hundredth
of a millimeter
controlled all digitally,
which is again a super important
aspect, making it all possible
to fit a million of these qubits
in a chip smaller
than a credit card.
It's this combination of
the reliability, the speed,
the size that makes the
topological approach so unique.
With Majorana 1, we had proven
out the foundational physics,
and with Majorana 2, now we
begin the engineering scale.
But ultimately -- yeah.
[ Applause ]
But ultimately, it is never
about tech for tech's sake.
It's about tackling those
pressing challenges
of people and planet.
It is also the fundamental
point of this conference.
The question is not whether you
can build the next-grade model,
the next-grade platform, or
even this quantum machine.
The question is, how do
we build this Frontier
ecosystem together?
Because there are really
two stories people can tell
about this moment.
One is that technology
concentrates power,
reduces human agency,
and leaves the society
to absorb the consequences.
The other is that we use this
next wave to unlock opportunity
for developers, scientists,
enterprises, and
every community.
And our job is to make
the second story true.
That's our North Star for
the Frontier ecosystem.
Let's all go build together.
Thank you all very, very much.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
David Shaw: This is one
of those rare moments
when something that once felt
beyond imagination suddenly
feels within reach.
[ Music ]
Quantum is our most
fundamental physical theory.
It's really the low-level
operating system
of the real physical world.
Sabrina Maniscalco:
For quantum computing
to deliver real-world impact,
it has to be both
reliable and scalable.
[ Music ]
David Shaw: Reaching quantum
at scale will allow us
to take a more direct approach
to solving problems
in chemistry --
Sabrina Maniscalco: The
discovery of new material.
David Shaw: Life sciences.
Sabrina Maniscalco: The way
in which we bring
drugs to market.
It opens up millions
of possibilities.
Quantum will change the world
and this change is just
beginning to happen.
[ Music ]